Excuse me!
…Excuse me!...No...
Always busy in here on a Friday night!
Sorry!
Could I just have a...
Patience and persistence!
Ahh, finally.
Yes, erm ok, I’d like a beer, please!
Sorry?
what kind?
Of beer?
Erm, lager, please.
Yeah, that'll do.
Sorry, what?
A half pint or a pint?
How big is a pint?
Yes.
OK, a pint.
Ok, great, I’d like a...
Oh, sorry.
Two pints of lager, please.
OK great, I’ll have...
Oh…and a packet of crisps.
Sorry.
What flavour?
Erm, let me just check.
Cheese and onion.
OK give me...
And a glass of wine.
Red, please.
Yes, I’m sure that’s it.
Thank you.
How much is that?
Let me just check my wallet.
I’ve got five, and that’s another six.
OK great, I’d like a pint of bitter and
two halves of lager please.
Cheers. Keep the change.
That’s how it's done!